All right,
welcome back to computer vision.
Today we're going to do
just a little bit on video.
Today and I guess next one will be our,
we're only going to talk two
of these lessons on video.
One could do almost an entire class on
computer vision as applied to video and
the things that are different.
But we're,
we're not going to do a lot of that.
A lot of what you've learned
can be applied obviously to
each of the individual images.
And some of what you have plearned,
what you've learned where they're
essentially two dimensional operators.
You can apply those same
operators in three dimensions.
Or other ways of thinking about video.
But we're only going to do a little.
In fact talking about
the three dimensions.
Video, we're going to think of as
a three dimensional signal, all right?
So video as, as shown here is,
I have this image x y and as time moves
forward, time could also go that way,
it is that I've got this volume of data.
And so a pixel inside a video is
actually a function of x, y and t.
All right so sometimes you'll see
me going like this for video and
I'm talking about x, y and t.
You know that,
that's the way I think of video: I
think of video as a volume of data.
So, let's talk a little bit about
some basic computer vision in video.
So, one might be object detection.
So, suppose your goal, and we'll talk
a little bit about this next time,
is activity recognition.
Right, you want to
recognize what's going on.
So you're going to recognize
the activity of objects,
of people that's there.
But, but there are these
entities doing something, so
you might have to find these entities.
That is, what are the things
in here that are moving,
that are doing something that I need
to try to label what their activity is.
You know, nominally, or
notionally, you can think of as my
goal is to find the independently
moving things that are in this video.
So here I've labeled this thing
called a background subtraction, and
it's you know, just example.
I mean here you have a, a scene
where there's some cars moving, and
the idea would be well, you know,
we'd like to be able to find all
of these moving blobs, all right?
In this particular case, all these
moving blobs are the moving objects.
Generically, background
subtraction is used a lot.
It used to be that people thought that
background subtraction was trivial and
then they thought it was hard and then
they stopped thinking about it at all.
It still, this notion of separating out
the entities is still a fundamental
research area in computer vision.
We're going to talk about
some simple stuff here.
So, the, the most straightforward
background subtraction is where you have
a static camera.
So the camera's not moving,
and the idea being that
if nothing is changing in the scene
then nothing is moving their either and
there's nothing to do, so
you should go home and get some rest.
All right?
Background subtraction
as sort of simple and
overly simplistic as it is,
it is used a lot in commercial systems.
Traffic monitoring where they're,
you know, counting cars, or, or
monitoring other things going on.
Various human action recognition
where you have people coming by and
you want to be able to say something
about walking, running, whatever.
Human-computer interaction.
So, people will build systems where
humans interact with a big display, and
to pull the humans out from
the background, they have to
remove the background somehow, and
sort of object tracking in general.
So, sometimes there, what you'll do is,
you'll compensate for
the motion of the camera, so
you'll move the whole image back.
As if you had the camera sta,
stationary and
then you do background
subtraction on that.